medical bills can really quickly add up
for covid patients as victoria saha
reports one man is realizing fighting to
recover from covet just half the battle
as he is now wondering how to pay a very
hefty hospital bill
63-year-old james sweeney was
unconscious from covett and had to be
put on a ventilator that was in november
so he had no say in who cared for him or
whether they were in network once he
woke up in february he asked about the
hospital bill i did ask the doctor and
the case manager about the bills because
i was even worried that he was told
insurance was covering it then an actual
bill showed up recently by his providers
showing the many claims that were denied
and that he now owes more than 80
thousand dollars
i keep waking up in the middle of night
trying to figure out how i'm going to
cover these bills he claims the total
cost of his stay was around 2 million
dollars his insurance paid most of it
since the hospital was a network but the
doctors at the hospital who are part of
a private medical group are not in
network
insurance broker patrick cassell
specializes in these cases he says
sweeney is not at fault
the doctors know if they're providers or
not so does the hospital facility so the
facility should definitely start sending
in doctors that are to coordinate that
care better casale says when it comes to
critical care involving life or death
insurance is supposed to cover all costs
victoria saha 8 news now victoria
reached out to the hospital group which
responded in part we have taken steps to
bring this issue to the attention of the
private medical group and the insurance
company and recommend this issue be
revisited that private group expected to
have an answer for us tomorrow on friday
a gofundme page for the sweeney family
is posted to our website we'll follow up